Good morning. Hank. It's Tuesday March 27th. I'm coming to you from NYU medical center where I'll be for at least one more day.
Sarah was like: 'Make sure they know you're sick!'
I'm sick: that's my IV port but I'm doing okay, and I'm doing a lot better since I watched your video.
Man, did that make my week.
You know, I've said thank you about Thirty-five thousand times in the last few days.
You say thank you every time the woman comes in and gives you a new IV.
You say thank you, when they bring you your food. You say thank you when the Yeti shows up.
I like the Yeti.
You say thank you when the yeti spends 12 hours a day here.
You say thank you every minute of every day basically because you're helpless, and you need a lot of help
and you're grateful for that help, but it's a very different thank you when you're saying
thank you to someone for going way above and beyond the call of duty.
He said duty.
And that's what you guys did.
Thank you in particular
but also all of the viewers to send in those pictures of stuff on their head and for me to be able to learn the
exciting spoiler that Ron Weasley is going to die by a suffocation in a plastic bag in The Deathly Hallows.
To learn all of the wonderful things that one can put on one's head from an ironing board to a large
knee-length boot. I don't know what else to say except
Thanks, nerdfighters. You guys are made of awesome. Anyway Hank the word on the street
Is that I should be getting out fairly soon - either tomorrow or Thursday
provided things continue to move along as they've been moving along.
If you look at it - it's way better.
Hmm look how much, look how much more white there is!
You're looking up my nose aren't you? You are. Dammit!
Hopefully, I will see you tomorrow, here...
...but you will see me on Thursday at 88th Street. Thanks again.